[Applaudissements]
depuis quelques années j'ai deux
questions que je trouve substantielle et
que j'aimerai bien partager avec vous la
première c'est comment se construire en
tant qu'homme et la deuxième il ya
toujours quelqu'un pour nous aider à
sortir de sa zone de confort nous sommes
le vendredi 12 avril 2013
j'ai pris l'avion avec à monsieur justin
avec un petit sac comme si j'allais chez
des gens ont un petit séjour et
curieusement quand ne soit vous arrivé à
l'aéroport a dû mandat donc voilà nous
sommes passés par les ports du fonds
ignorait pourquoi je ne savais pas ce
qui se passait
j'allais juste avec ce monsieur
j'ai 14 ans à cette époque
j'habite avec ma mère mes frères et
soeur et mon beau père dans une banlieue
de luanda en angola
ça s'appelle sambizanga c'est un mélange
des quartiers pauvres comme dans les
quartiers nord de marseille et les
favelas de rio
ma famille est pauvre et sans ressources
mon père est décédé il ya quelques
années maintenant nous sommes 7 et julie
quatrième de la famille avec un grand
frère et deux grandes soeurs ma
grossesse elle a eu un enfant à 17 ans
et les autres enfants ils sont plus
petits comme dans beaucoup de familles
qui vivent là bas il est très difficile
de s'en sortir
souvent les jeunes ils tombent dans la
délinquance pour subvenir aux besoins de
leur famille mon grand frère pour par
exemple il a été touché par ce phénomène
les gens de là-bas nous voient aucun
avenir pour eux beaucoup veulent quitter
le pays pour aller au brésil ou au
portugal
c'est peut-être ça qui a poussé ma mère
à se dire qu'elle devait offrir autre
chose pour ces enfants
il n'a pas voulu que je connaisse le
même sort que mon frère il n'a aucune
formation
il ne sait lire ni écrire
aujourd'hui il a deux enfants ou alors
comme ma soeur il ya eu un enfant à 17
ans en produisons le même schéma que ma
mère ya eu un enfant quand elle avait 17
ans de monsieur qui m'emmenait il avait
dit à ma mère qu'on échange d'argent
l'aller on voyait son frère son fils en
europe et là bas
il allait pouvoir faire des études à
l'école
il allait avoir une famille et qu'il
pouvait se faire adopter pour par une
famille et que lorsque cette famille
alors est décédé il allait hériter de
tous ses biens
ma mère ne m'a pas demandé mon avis
parce qu'elle savait caisse mac qui si
elle m'avait demandé je n'aurais jamais
accepté de partir avec ce monsieur qui
était en vérité un passeur et quand je
sors de l'avion je ne sais pas où je
suis ni même dans quel pays je parle que
le portugais je ne comprends rien à ce
que j'entends je ne comprend pas la
langue et je pense maintenant que
c'était à bordeaux même si je ne suis
pas sûr nous prenons le bus qui nous
sommes arrivés à la gare de nantes
la première nuit je la passe dans la rue
hélas le passeur qui me les sols je
garde juste mon pad mes papiers
qui me servait de carnet de famille il a
pris mon argent alors que ma mère y en
avait donné pour moi la première nuit je
la passe dans la rue et je ne sais
toujours pas où je suis je ne comprend
pas un mot de ce que j'entends un
congolais s'intéresse à moi vous
connaissez une association et m'ont même
en étant là bas il appelle un traducteur
et puis momen à la police
et puis je me retrouve dans une employée
enfants à saint nazaire chez toute une
série de tests pour connaître mon vrai
âge une série de test médical pendant
deux ou trois mois on met dans un
collège en classe de troisième parce que
je ne savais pas parler français et
ensuite je vais au lycée professionnel à
chalon pour nazaire
et puis je déménage en famille d'accueil
à machecoul j'ai toujours aimé lire et
les livres c'était le seul cadeau que
j'ai eue de ma mère cette passion pour
la lecture qui m'a aidé à prendre nos
français du coup je me suis acheté un
petit dictionnaire et un petit carnet où
je notais précieusement des mots avec
ces mots je construisais des phrases
pour me permettre de de faire des
conversations avec les gens je
m'engageais dans une conversation en
guise d'entraînement et ainsi j'ai
rempli des pages et des pages
oui les cards et je les ai encore
même si maintenant ça me semble ridicule
d'avoir appris ainsi le français se
portant ainsi que j'ai appris à parler
le français
et puis au lycée notre dame à chalon
j'ai rencontré des professeurs
extraordinaires et j'admire beaucoup
beaucoup ont aidés ils ont eu la la
générosité de m'offrir des livres que
j'ai dévoré comme le petit pays de
galles faille ou encore l'alchimiste de
paulo coelho maintenant grâce à eux
aujourd'hui je suis en licence banques
assureront 100g et j'aimerais bien lire
jusqu'au doute en doctorat si possible
en fait en cinq ans j'ai obtenu la
nationalité française
les diplômes comme le bep brevet des
collèges le bac avec mention bien et le
bts par la force
elle a soif de réussite
grâce à tout ça j'ai compris qu'il est
possible à toutes les personnes
d'obtenir plein de choses jeunes ou
moins jeunes
cette histoire elle peut vous paraître
extraordinaire inimaginable voir
invraisemblable guy qui me croirait en
angola ou même en france
qui croirait que je serai là aujourd'hui
devant vous dans un pays que je ne
connaissais même pas il y a 6 ans et
pourtant c'est vrai en réalité ce fut
une succession de hasards et qu' avec le
recul je peux prendre comme un coup de
chance
alors comment j'analyse cette histoire
avec le recul
comment cet événement comment ces
personnes m'ont conduit ou plutôt m'ont
forcée il faut comprendre que pendant
des années je n'ai voulu à tout le monde
c'est dur de ne pas trouver sa place
alors qu'il faut se battre constamment
pour s'intégrer surtout tenir le coup
psychologiquement ces personnes c'est
d'abord ma mère je me suis longtemps
demandé pourquoi il avait fait ça je
vais il voulu pendant longtemps car
c'était c'est la personne que j'aime le
plus au monde
c'était comme si on m'avait arraché un
bout de moi parce que je n'avais aucune
nouvelle de ma famille j'ai essayé de
trouver des explications
j'ai eu des moments de révolte comme un
bouc-émissaire c'était ma famille
d'accueil
j'ai compris il ya deux ou trois ans que
ça se passait souvent comme ça avec
l'afrique et les passeurs
maintenant
je sais que c'est à cause d'elle mais
aussi grâce à elle que je suis ici parce
qu'elle n'a pas elle n'a pas voulu que
je connaisse le même sort que les années
que j'ai laissé là-bas en angola
merci mon nom et notre personne c'est le
monsieur lui qui avait pris les papiers
et mon argent
c'était un voleur mais je ne lui ouvre
pas à cause de lui j'étais devenu
apatride
j'étais passé de légal et l'illégal
malheureusement aujourd'hui jeu subit
encore les conséquences de ce vote de
papier
enfin en france tous ces gens qui m'ont
entouré pris en charge
ma famille d'accueil malgré nos conflits
et m'apporter de la connaissance dans la
culture est un peu d'amour
les professeurs ils m'ont beaucoup
soutenu et m'ont apporté leur conseil
ma petite copine depuis plus de trois
ans il m'a toujours aidé toujours
soutenu et m'a aidé à me construire et
je me sens soutenu quoi qu'il arrive
tous ces gens je les remercie de m'avoir
bousculé et de m'avoir sorti de ma zone
de confort
je ne vends pas toute ma vie ici en
france mais je sais que j'irai au bout
de ce que j'ai commencé j'ai souvent dit
aujourd'hui j'ai pas mangé les demain je
mangerai j'ai grandi avec ça et je
vivrai avec ça y compris pour aider ma
famille
pour l'instant je ne sais pas comment
mais il n'y arrive pas aujourd'hui j'y
arriverai demain grâce à mon histoire
j'ai pu comprendre que avec le temps
j'ai pu accomplir des choses que je
n'aurais jamais imaginé j'ai découvert
aussi que je pouvais rêver y ait des
capacités en moi que je ne pouvais
jamais que je n'aurais jamais soupçonnée
voilà mais grâce à mon histoire
je crois qu'il est possible de se
construire en tant qu'homme même en
étant loin de sa famille tout en partant
de zéro
quelle que soit son origine
il est possible de vivre ensemble pour
satisfaire le besoin de s'accomplir et
de réussir
simple exige tanguay les ch'tis montre
d'autres laddh suspect landes
il ya toujours quelqu'un de notre côté
du monde qui pas tant
[Applaudissements]